Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Rogue one video for
all the Easter eggs the references to the
other films in the canon.
They even had stuff from the TV shows in there
too, so here we go.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the movie yet the IMAX giveaway still going
on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss out on anything.
So there's a whole lot of the other movies
inside this movie.
It features a lot of characters that show
up during episode four, but the title itself
is an Easter egg for Rogue squadron Rogue
one is are like the beginning of the idea
for Rogue squadron.
Like this in the movie there is no Rogue one
will there is now was sort of the birth of
that Rogue squadron would go on to become
the most elite fighter unit inside the rebellion
and then eventually the new Republic during
the expanded universe novels the villain Orson
Karen it wore a white uniform, it's kind of
an Easter egg for grand Adm. throne from the
expanded universe that there are other imperials
that wear white uniforms his special elite
troopers called death troopers were in the
black uniforms or actually an Easter egg from
Jedi Knight to Jedi outcast the videogame
or they appeared as death troopers for the
first time.
So there even Easter eggs for the videogames
and here's the really old video games to Mads
Mikkelsen's character named Galen is also
named after Galen Marek star killer from the
force unleashed star killer was Darth Vader's
apprentice sodas all looping it back around
the saw Gerrera character was featured during
season five of the clone wars is also getting
ready to show up on Star Wars rebels.
So speaking of which there are a bunch of
Star Wars rebels Easter eggs the ghost shows
up on Javan for when they land it's on another
landing pad just sitting there at Capt.
by Syndulla who is general Syndulla gets a
shout out during Rogue one like you literally
hear someone call for general Syndulla.
So for those that don't know Rogue one happens
after the events of Star Wars rebels, so she's
risen in the ranks of the rebels to become
a general when they learn about the rebels
going to the Imperial archives to steal the
death Star plans chopper roles by Mon Mothma
and then during the battle little bit later
in the movie you see the ghost enter the fray.
So like it's here in this big Starfield here
and here the character pow shout one of Zeb's
famous curse words Paribas as he's charging
the beach.
So this last was a bit of a stretch, but the
hammerhead Corvette the gets the shout out
the belongs to Princess Leia.
Obviously a big reference to what happens
at the beginning of episode four.
But during the events of Star Wars rebels
they explain how the rebellion comes into
possession of those and how Princess Leia
gets one herself.
So whole bunch of rebels in their they ended
up using a bunch of the animated stuff even
though it's very lightly and kind of in the
background.
But then you have very big things like Khyber
crystals which actually started out in splinter
of the mind's eye the crystals that most Jedi
use inside their light sabers being refined
and used to power the death Star laser.
So that is why the super laser is green.
There was also some abandon storyline from
George Lucas when he was first conceiving
of episode for the use the Khyber crystals
a sort of MacGuffin, but that storyline was
abandoned and it became the death Star plans.
It was the blue milk at the beginning of the
film sort of like Luke Skywalker's beginning
living with Abreu and uncle Owen before things
went sideways the imperials came in quite
end with the charred skeletons that they didn't
episode four, but you may have noticed that
Mon Mothma the actress that played her was
the same one who played her during revenge
of the Sith.
It was actually deleted seen so you might
of ecstasy in the movie if you have the DVD
but it's another one of those Obi-Wan Kenobi
Ewan McGregor situations whereby an actor
plays a younger version of the character they
get a little bit older in real life.
But the characters themselves are also aged
up in these new movies.
So in real life she becomes a more age-appropriate
Monmouth month for the time period of this
movie, you may recognize barest and sell me
from game of thrones.
There are a lot of familiar faces from genre
TV.
He was playing general Jan to Donna who is
a very big figure during episode four.
Then of course you all recognize Jimmy Smits
is Baylor gotta coming back from the prequel's.
So he made a number of references to other
people as he was leaving to go back to Oliver
on that we know how that ends but he talks
about trusting someone with his life he's
talking about his daughter, Princess Leia
who they brought back just like grandma off
target and with digital reproduction in the
Jedi that he was going to contact was Obi-Wan
Kenobi in hiding on Tatooine waiting for Luke
Skywalker to come of age.
Things were happening pretty quickly at the
end of the film.
So if you didn't pick up on it.
They were like literally taking the plans
to Princess Leia just barely got there is
Darth Vader was slicing them down in is there
pulling away from the wreckage he chases them
down in the opening moments of episode four.
So effectively what you could do the way this
is design is that you can make a super cut
by just jamming Rogue one in episode four
together in their be a seamless transition
between the end of that movie in the beginning
of episode four.
Who could forget walrus man Jen actually bumps
into Dr. Cornelius and walrus man who are
just as big of ass holes before he runs into
Obi-Wan Kenobi in the cantina and they both
get themselves killed, so there were a ton
of people in this movie that showed up right
before you knew they were getting ready to
died during episode four.
So let's talk about grandma off target and
coming back this is actually reportedly some
of the changes they made late on in the film
decided at a lot more of him, but whether
you guys liked it or not they totally brought
him back to life with a digital reproduction.
I really think that if you're younger person
Singh this movie it probably didn't bother
you as much but if you're an older person
and you understand that the actor that playing
him died a long time ago.
Then it gets a little bit weird, so you can
jump over that hurdle I think it was okay
just as long as they don't do this all the
time like I want to see Anna cannon like every
character that's ever died come back the digital
reproduction in every single movie more Empire
stuff the sick she gets really cool Vader's
castle on most of far this is actually taken
from original art that Ralph McQuarrie did
for return of the Jedi that was then later
scrapped get a palace that was supposed to
be on a volcano planet.
Later, George Lucas made the prequel's that
became most of far, so that is where his temple
is how fitting that he build it on the side
of that epic fight with Obi-Wan Kenobi the
box.
The tank was also a really nice touch to it's
not necessarily an Easter egg for Empire strikes
back Luke in the box the tank but it definitely
invokes a lot of that imagery the temple that
Donnie Yen in the other people were supposed
to be guarding before the Whills all went
away or were killed is actually a reference
to the Whills the George Lucas originally
wrote into is for Star Wars treatment.
It was originally called the adventures of
Luke star killer as taken from the journals
of the Whills so nice real big deep cut for
original George Lucas stuff they do that a
lot the try to include little Easter eggs
from things that George Lucas cut out a long
time ago from his original scripts were from
original Ralph McQuarrie Art like Darth Vader's
palace.
There were all kinds of verbal references
to jokes from other people in the Star Wars
franchise like K2S0 making the joke about
the odds of him being shot with her blaster
they are high very high in that we have to
talk about all those names that Jen read off
when they were looking for the Stardust plans
in the archive so she's scrolling down a bunch
of random names for plans of buildings and
projects and finally says lack saber.
There was a giant group of people in my theater
that screamed when they said that name people
are like of the talking about the dark saber.
What's going on here is this something is
going to come back into the Canon because
there is no such thing as black saber in the
Star Wars universe right now.
So that's really just them teasing something
coming they could have been talking about
Darth Vader's super star destroyer, the executor,
but that's probably not it is probably just
something else is there throwing out there
that they can pick up and run with in the
new films.
So the dark saber is a black belated light
saber that was constructed during the Old
Republic era that was stolen by Manda Lorenz
and appeared during the clone wars episodes
when Obi-Wan Kenobi was on Mangalore later
it passed into the possession of Darth Maul
who then brought it back on Star Wars rebels
recently in a recent episode, so the dark
saber has made it full circle.
So just remember that archive is an archive
of all the giant buildings and big construction
projects that the Empire is building.
So whatever black saber is it some giant project,
so there was a book in the expanded universe
called dark saber that was basically like
a smaller version of the death Star.
It was mostly just the super laser, with like
very little construction around it.
So it was built to look like a giant light
saber you guys can let me know what was your
favorite Easter eggs you spot a during Rogue
one and what do you think that black saber
is a reference to if there were any Easter
eggs you guys spotted that I did not include
in the video just write them below in the
comments.
There were thousands of visual things really
small behind-the-scenes details that we probably
will find out about, so we watch the film
like a billion more times.
So good to be doing a bunch of Star Wars stuff
in the next couple of weeks, but am going
to wait to do some more spoilery stuff till
next week after everybody gets a chance to
see the movie, I'll talk about Darth Vader
anthology films and why there's probably not
going to be one really it stems from the idea
of scarcity like there were a couple Darth
Vader lines in the movie that I felt like
were weird he's better when he's not talking
it just being super menacing like that end
fight when he just slashing them all down.
No words just going to town.
But I also have a really cool flash versus
Iris West video them to post tomorrow morning
and then the be some game of thrones walking
dead on Monday.
So I'll just post updates on the video schedule
as I post new videos while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for my review
the movie and you can click here for a couple
big DC trailers that I just dropped thank
you so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight!